welcome to this video playing crap huh
Blanca yeah one of the funnier handles
let's see what happens he's a really
good blood splits player so I'm going to
see when we get here Stonewall nope all
right interesting delays delaying okay I
don't want to play Knight c3 because of
a specific set up okay he allows Bishop
e3 quite willingly Oh interesting so
he's not going to Castle as what he's
saying right okay so 95 runs into Bishop
takes h2o interesting night e to F for
maybe
so night f-for king of seven is the idea
what probably I am going to start with
this this move and now yeah not sure I
shouldn't be too slow here this is very
important what his playing is not really
good but it is quick and this might come
to hurt me later so maybe just rocks you
on him and see about it i mean i don't
really believe in this attack very much
or what whatever this is but still
Bishop f5 it's not going to work play
that
whenever should just pile up here or
this one 495 I mean pile up on the C
file I mean main dangerous falling too
far behind on the clock okay I don't
understand it sorry don't understand
this kind of play m95 now or takes takes
Knight g4 okay tripti 7y okay gets the
Bishop to d7 then getting something
developed okay it doesn't have any
square you know but hmm check I have no
def wanna check
also 95 is just okay I mean why not I
simply don't take ever no reason to this
this kind of situation everything is a
completely save him okay if a chick now
Roxy 7 I don't want to trade Quincy
really that much there's no wind here
how to believe 96 Bishop cheeks check on
c700 there's no win check I'm just a bit
slow here
check ya got their time we really played
that Jack a complete I have no words I
don't know I don't know how to call that
but one minute something I mean really
with total disregard for the position
just playing any any nonsense okay so
it's still difficult i have no time and
queen a king edge for is kind of coming
that's a draw Kim's you to King edge for
time morning I don't see how I can win
here really check check it's not very
satisfying but I cannot play for win I
don't see how check
I didn't have couldn't calculate this
really so of course just a pawn mostly
check check check
I have 34 seconds there are some chances
to do that check check check check check
check check is playing on time the whole
whole game basically complete disregard
of the possession or whatever just check
being quick and hope oh that's nice
black resign yes you deserve that really
playing this nonsense all the time just
just trying to win on time yeah I
screwed the total wind up here of course
this wasn't really well played here I
have to take in a little bit more time
to finish the game off right away it
really shouldn't be like that we should
be 67 I mean yes yeah I should keep
Queens on but I already felt the time
pressure its difficulty is just dashing
out move off to move up to move as bad
as it was it was quick Jackie after that
he's kind of in the game again check
this is a draw now which I saw that he
didn't want to draw of course he just
wants to win on time check so he
continued playing for loss and 92 was
made in one
I mean I wasn't instant move mode so I
didn't see that yeah this wins as well
again 92 I mean he never looked at the
position even I mean I had no time this
is my excuse overlooking this made all
of the time it's still a made all of the
time 92 mate I never thought about that
the night on f4 I just never crossed my
mind that I should move this piece I
mean it it was basically pre moves check
check yeah I again you can t must take
the draw catch ya is just worse it was a
draw again but what can I do I really
have to play those instruments all of
the time check check check chanting much
that I can do and then he somehow yeah
somehow blunder you look probably
because of pre moving up removing all
the time and rook g1 was a pretty
logical move yeah I don't know this is a
weird player he had some really good
games against me buddy tried to play
good moves but I mean he stopped this
this general concept of trying to play
good moves really early on here this is
already really bad for like think that
was it was quite ok night f also came
into consideration yeah and he simply
has no square for this night it took me
ages to play at me and he I just didn't
take it yeah I mean you cannot play like
that really only if you don't care about
the game itself if you just want to win
on time ok well thanks for watching